abone ol
bu
[Alkış]
duyguları zoruna
dünyanın diğer ucuna gitmeyi göze
alabilir misin
Sonra oradan aldığımız ilhamla bu
tutkuyu ailenize doğup büyüdüğü köye
getirme cesaretimiz Olur mu
merhaba Ben Deniz Toprak Bugün size
Sizler kadar orduyu zaman hikayemizi
dalgalardan altın planlamak için
buradayım
abone ol
ya dalga sesi nereden alır nereye bilir
bilmez değil En yolculuğun tam ortasına
bak
yoksa yolculuğun kendisi bir gizemli
olan nereye varacağını bilmemek mi
Belki ya Her yolculuğu soğuk Yeni Bir
Başlangıç değildir işte bizim de
hikayesi olarak burada yani yolda
başlıyor yol beni hep bir insanlarla
bambaşka hikayeler çalıştırdı lise
yıllarında İdare eder yaptı gönüllü
çalıştım bu eserlerde kaldım
Bir ay boyunca Google'da İngilizce
öğretmeni yaptığımda oldu E o zaman
kadar bir Okulu köy okulu yenilenmesinde
çalıştı
Tüm bu hikayeleri arasında
2010 yılıydı çok iyi hatırlıyorum ve
Meksika'da
dalga sörfü tecrübemi deneyimledim çok
iyi hatırlıyorum Çünkü o
diyenler var burada ilk dalgayı almayı
sıbobu Heijan
o Ooo çok yakın Çünkü o gün O günler bir
daha hiç eskisi gibi olmadı Ben
hayatımın geri kalanında
söz yapabildiğim denize yakın
olabildiğim gecemi bundan sağladım
yetmez dünyaya bu vesileyle bir fayda
Yarattım hayatın hayalini kuruyorum
bu tür bu yolculukları keşiflerin
arasında bir de Türkiye'nin yavrularını
eğitimi tamamlamış adım oldu Az önce
Üniversitesi Kimya mühendisliğinden
mezun oldu
uluslararası
havalı bir şirkette yöneticilik kariyeri
yaparken bir yandan da
dünyanın öbür ucunda Sırlar kadarda
İstanbul kurmanın sonuna geliyordu
aynı anda iki farklı yerde olacağız gibi
ayrı Hz Bayram iki farklı lokasyonda iki
farklı Hayat da sürdürmek ve mümkün
değil birini seçmem gerekiyordu ve ben
2017'de silah göstereceğim ve 2018'de
silah ve görüşelim
Evet şimdi bakıyorum silahı nereye
geldim ama elimde ne var
evinden binlerce kilometre uzaktayım
hediye bilemediği bilmediğin
sektöründeyim ve posta işletme Restoran
üretilen sözler seni aramam gerekiyor
bu kulaktan dolma bildiği kurallarını
kulaktan dolma biri gelişmemiş 3. diğer
ülkesindeyim ve ülkedeki şeyi adada
kimseyi tanımıyorum
Bu ip söyle Yeni başlayanlara etkilidir
enişte karşımıza çıkar tüm değişkenler
ile rog
akıntıyı Rüzgar dalga bunları hiç Doğal
olmak senin ilişki nasıl bir ilişki
varsa nasıl bir yolun varsa sende o
formları ona göre yükselen diyorsunuz
hepimiz gayet iyi biliyoruz değil mi bu
Karadeniz'in ne kadar tehlikeli
bildiğiniz olduğunu duymuşsunuzdur
hikayeleri Korkut Hikayeleri akıttı sana
şeker sonra şeker şöyle bulursunuz şöyle
ölürsünüz gibi korkutucu hikayeleri
bu eğer
akıntıyı eğer akıntının nasıl
çalıştığını Sen bilmiyorsan akıntı seçip
korkutucu Hatta tehlikeli bir şey
dönüşebilir
Percy Eğer bakıldığında çalıştığı
biliyorsa akıntısına hizmet ederseniz de
ile çalışan bir şey dönüşebilir
O çok çok korkuyorum Hani birbirine
karıştırdınız
korku esasında sağlıklı Hani ikisi
tehlikelidir
bu korku ve kaygıları ile yüzleşmeye
biri bir şey nasıl tasarlanabilir
bu işte ben de korku ve kaygıların da
yüzleşmeye başladım O gün daha iyi
anladım Benimle gerçekten ne var
sen böylesin sayılara mıyım aynı
düşünmeyi severim farklı senaryolarla
çalışmayı kuraklık olmayı
biz bu insanları biraraya getirmek ve
onların birbirlerinden beslenemediği bir
ortam yaratmak benim için en az söz
kadar büyük bir tutku
Tüm bu elimde olanları Aslında gerçekten
deli de ne var daha iyi anladım da o
zaman bir baktım ki ki sırada
göstericiler bambaşka bir yere gitmiş ya
her şey inanılmaz güzel gidiyor Buse
oturmuş
çok kısa bir süre içinde işlerimiz çok
şükür çok yoluna girmiş hiç deneylere
değil diğer oldu olmuş olsa da bu Kendi
elimde gerçekten değil sahip olduğunu
anladığında işleri bir şekilde yolu sok
muşuz
bir terslik var
o
odaya Rüya hayatı yaşamaya geldim öyle
profil İtalya'da 12 ay yaz işte
dalgalarda her gün söyle bu bilgi
hayatın hayalini eğitim oraya ben ve
kendimi böyle inanılmaz çalışırken çok
yoğun çalışırken bu gece döndü misafir
geliyor bir santimetre içeri oluyor
Burası yerleştiriyorum çekimi yapıyorum
odaları Ben 8 yokluyorum doğru düzgün
ettik güveneceğim Beni bul olmuşum oraya
hayatta çok bir kalsın içinde bulmuşum
yani
bu yıllarında be daha iyi senin yapmayı
çok severim Çok severim sonra ne olduysa
bu peşine düşmedim izin verir hikaye
gelen geri kalan kısmını veriyorum
hikâyesinde de size bitince Biz de
bitirdim işçisine birkaç bölümde
anlatmak istiyorum
Selam bugün çok sıcak hava Neydi o
sizlerden Adası ve o sıcak içindeki
adres sormam gerekiyor İlkokulu gördüm
orada
fotokopi içine girdi adresi soracağım
çok tatlı güler yüzlü bir kız vardı
silahların olduğu gibi inanılmaz güler
yüzlü çok enerjilerini güzel Ben sorayım
dedim ya insanın çocuk vardı İngilizce
bilen bana yardımcı olabilecek
kız arıyorum bana yardımcı olacak
işlerden biri var mı kadar çaresiz
bırakmıştı hemen aralarında konuşmaya
başladı Bir nerede senin bana verdi
ben
konuştum bugün
Yok kanka o günden sonra ben o silahla
çalışmaya başladı ve randevu o günden
beri son güçleri üstüne yaşlı zamandır
bizimle beraber ben onun başında
melodiler operasyonun başında ve bütün
işlerin sorumluluğunu yönetiyor bu
işlerini güzelleştirdi en güzeli de
bütün bu sürekli inanılmaz keyif aldık
ve be sigara kadar kalkıp başka dünyanın
farklı yani Başka işler yapmak için o
senden uzaklaşabilir olduk Yani ona
güvenebileceğim
hep gelme şunu Hatırlatırım Ne kadar
şanslısın gerçekten diye
Acaba Uşak bu insanlar
bursalılar her karşınıza hepimize
çıkıyor mu peki ya biz olursa da
çıktığında Bu fırsatları bu şarjlı bu
insanları kuşaklama yine kadarız bunu
düşünmenizi istiyorum size anladım
O bizim böyle yeşil tarif ediyor
birazdan Rüya hayata yaklaşmışım tamam
mı Söyle falan yapıyorum artık keyfim
yerinde
de sizin arkadaki yerimizi hostelde
öteki yaşam alanında nasıl çevirilir
diye düşünüyorum yani burayı insanların
birbirinden beslendiği hayatında birisi
bıraktığı yazılı götürmek istiyorum
ama böyle fikirlerimi heyecanını
paylaşacaktır birine ihtiyacım var Beni
anlayacak ve köründe önünü açacağı işte
sanatçı bakışıyla bir yolu geliştirecek
bilirdi Tam o sırada bir mesaj geldi
Yağmur Ona sinirlendi ya da kalacak yer
aradım yani tatil yapmak istediğinden
bahsediyor böyle o zaman yavru kuzum ne
kadar önemli olduğunu bilmiyorum şimdi
Fotoğrafçılık kariyerine biyografi
kariyerine bilmiyorum sanatçı kimliği
tanımıyorum Hadi abi de kızıl olduğunu
bilmiyorum yağmur geliyor
ve diğer eşarp polisine tekrar geliyor
altı ay kalıyor Deniz yaratıkla kırıp
kırıp yeni dönüştürüyoruz Merhaba
fikirleriyle net örgüyle sürekli önünü
açıyor sürü yeni şeyler ekliyor içeride
öğrenmeye başlıyoruz beraber şeyler
çekmeye başlıyor ilk yıllarında fark
ettiğim bir heyecanı var demiştik ya ya
o da tekrar içerik üretmeye hikaye
anlatma Hatta benim çekme alanında ilham
oluyor bu fikirler veriyor ve biz
yağmurla beraber konserler festivaller
sanatçıları ağırlıyoruz inanılmaz bir
yere dönüştürüyoruz insanlar ve yola
girip hayatına dair kararlar almaya
başlıyor ya Ya kaderini değiştiriyor
yaşadığı yer değiştiriyor seni dalgayı
taşıyor portekiz'e taşıyor yaptığı işi
değiştiriyor ve hayatımda iz bırakan bir
yere dönüşüyor bu ya geldiği şeklindeki
Hoş geldin çok bir yaşam alanına
dönüşüyoruz
ve
bütün bu ihli süreçler içinde
e2019 yılında
grubu geliyor bize hadi yapmaya işte
yoga kapları oluyor ya
ne yaptığını grup geliyor orada bir kız
var
aradı 90 Op.Dr tarifleri
bir tane kız arkadaşım ilk defa orada
tanışıyoruz yoksa
1091 silahla Usta ile tanıştıktan sonra
o yaz Çünkü bizim şairlerimiz nasıl
yoğun sezon2 kafayı sarısı çok yoğun
olacağız ne kadar ayı daha sonra
haziran'dan itibaren de ben tatil
yaparım
Sadece şimdi yoksa
bu orduya Perşembe gidelim mi
Bu perşembe günü doğduğu yer ailenin
köklerinin olduğu yerde babaannenin hala
yaşadığı yer
Perşembe küçüklüğümde yaz aylarında
giderdiniz
bu yaz deme gidiyorsunuz kardeşler için
fındık eve
Babam dokuz gayet iyi bildiği için
bu tarz dizisi fındıktan önce ve
yazdıktan sonra ayarladık ki Fındıklı
500'e kalmasın
ya Ben bütün bu yaz dönemlerinde Babam
da geldikten sonra 17 süreç içerisinde
de olanda şeyin hayalini kurardık ya
keşke perşembe de proje yapılsa da
gençler kasabada kalsa heyecandan salar
geçmez geleceklerini koyacağım da
üzerine bursalar bunu hayali kurardı
bu
90 benimle Perşembeyi tatile gidiyor mu
kendi derdine düşüyor o kasanın markası
var ileri dönüşüm olarak arkamızda
gördüğünüz bu odadaki ürünleri üretmeye
Pro sanatı kumaşları dizisi peşine
düşüyor orada kaybolan zanaattır
araştırıyor amcalarda teyzelere
tanışıyor ve bugün yoksa son üç yıl en
son bir yıl içerisinde Üç Maymun de üç
farklı koleksiyon çıkartıyor adım
perşembeden çıkardı Biz bunları perşembe
de fotoğraflarda gördüğünüz orada
çekimlerini yapıyoruz
Yok yok Salı
Fatihi yaptığımız sırada Ordu'da bir
anda şunu düşünüyorum
var ya iyi hoş ama ben bütün bu güzel
hayata yasina kadar çok güzel dediniz
vardır yeni kenarında bir evimiz var 12
ay yazışıyoruz tropikal yanındayız kendi
var yani Ama bütün bunlara Ben bugün söz
sayesinde Elif'e bildim Bu da bana söyle
olan tutkumu denize olan tutkumu
paylaşmak istiyorum yüklüyor Bir şekilde
bunu da perşembe de doğduğu ailenin
doğduğu yerden daha güzel bir yerde
Yapamam diye düşünüyorum Sen de üzülür
ki Karadeniz ile Karadenizli arasında
iletişim kopukluğu oluşmuş birisi
tehlike görüşmüş gıdaları alıyoruz ya
uzatıyoruz onda
o ilk bu daha sözünü değiştirileceği
düşünüyoruz neden Perşembe lisesindeki
çocuk sözler söyler misin
Heyecanlı bir şey verdi mi çocuğa ve
üzerine
heyecanından geçici sağlayacak icat
arttırma başka bir yere gitmesine gerek
yok zaten
burada gençler söndü dersi versin
Eve
geldim ben çok inanılmaz
heyecanlanıyorum aklımıza var bir soru
geliyor ama
harika oraya bayıldı kaşar perşembedeki
Doğa hukukun mazlık bahçelik dışa
acaba burada bizi heyecanlandıracak
dalgalar var mı Yani bu yedi hayalini
kurduğumuz Nestle Pro bileceğimiz o da
lgailesi var mı
o
Telefonu çalıyor beni namaz bütün Bu
hikaye gerçek Bu arada tam olarak da
böyle bu insanlarla tanışıyorum
bu
Kredi değil mi tadında
gelebildiğini yeni Amerikalı bir adam
beni arıyor orta bir arkadaşımızdan
geçirdiğimiz alıp ve bana diyor ki
denizdeki dalgaları ve Karadeniz'deki
sözlüsü ve merak ettiğini söylüyor ve
bununla ilgili bir yapmak istediğinden
bahsediyor
çok tuhaf ara
Ama bazen insanlar hepimiz Daha doğrusu
birşeyleri ararken çok uzaklara bakarız
Ben de dalga ve sordum peşinden dünyanın
videolarına giderken ağzında o
babaannenin Köye bile beş dakika
uzaklıkta dünya standardında Dağı
olduğunu fark etmemişim
o bana mesaj attıktan sonra yer sonra
Perşembe geliyor grip
en son bir senedir 47 Perşembe geldi
Eğer geldi Ortalama bir ay kaldı
o ilk ayrı zaman kayıtlı iki farklı
değildi adamla tanıştık Serhat Bey
uyandığımda ve onlarla beraber çalışmaya
başladı onlarda İstanbul'da ortaya göç
etmiş Prodüksiyon ekibi bu ve onlarla
inanılmaz hikayeler
başladık iki farklı dünyaca ünlü sözcüğü
Profesyonel sözcüğü Perşembe
getirdikleri dalgaları keşfetmek ve olan
hikayenin çekmek için bizim şu an bu ilk
olarak Serhat Bu bir vekilin de beraber
yayınlanma aşamasında iki tane soru
Filmimiz var
o geldi mi o Elif yıllarında fark ettim
heyecanı var ya kendimi java2d
beraberlik yapımcısı olarak buldum biraz
da o
oh oh hikaye geliyor kemerlerinizi
bağlayın bu diziler ortamda girmeye
devam ediyoruz
Bu çok güzel bir gün orada soluklanacak
bir kapı aramışsınız
atakum'a yazıyorum Sen kendi derdine
düşmüş Ben de pazarlık yapıyor burada
soğuklarda kaldı sorduğumuzda yeter abla
biz ediyorlar çok tatlı bir kafe var
bayılırsınız Tüm ölçüsünde tam sizlik
İtalyan kafa ver diyorlar
bari ismi belli
O bizim köye gidiyoruz bir okuyoruz
Şimdi söyle hetero Dizayn edilmiş eve
göz nuru muhteşem bir yenilesi Cafe
300 gençler dolu
bir kafede iyi gelişir görünce o bize
yağ veriyor Demek ki orada yeni bir
şeyler yaptığında ve risk aldığında
insanlar dalgası gençler ufak bir ediyor
diye onu görüyoruz Bu bize
heyecanlandırıyor
çevirdiğimizde Cafe'nin sahibi haliyle
çalışıyoruz ay başlıyoruz anlatmaya yok
Çünkü ben yaptım yok Bunu ben yaptım
Pencereden lamba yaptım oradan masa
yaptım işte gelin artık taşın görüşürsün
falan filan diye içeri sokuyor İçerisi
atölye acı bana bu çıkıyor yeni nesil
bir zarar Care
haliyle bizim dostluğumuz o gün işimiz
Kahveyle kalmıyor iki yıl boyunca daha
da derinleşerek devam ediyor
bu Ali Ordu'da insanların abi ya şöyle
bir şey var kafamda bunu nasıl
yapabilirim diye gittikleri ara
bu Ali ben söyle başlatıyor kuşu
kırılmıyor soğuk havada gidiyor benimle
çok güzel söylüyor
bu hali Tabii bu işi de olduğu için
bakıyor şu sonra haftası Ulan ben bunu
yaparım diyor
Ve aleykümselam Yağız yapmaya başlıyor
bu yavru tatil yerine getirdim ve bugün
ortadaki söyle Okulumuzun söz
arkalarında Fatsa'da bu değil Ali
üretiyor ve önümüzdeki sene yanında
gençler ile çalışacağım
bu tahta bir nasıl sporları malzemeleri
ve ettiği gibi tesis kuruyor
ne soruyorlar
bu Karadeniz'de söz nereden çıktı diye
biz buraya iyice çıkarmaya geldik
alışkanlıklarınızı değiştirecek bir
hikaye yaratmaya geldik
Karadeniz'deki denize kendi denize
sırtını dönenler yani denizinden
uzaklaşanlar sizlere söz veriyorum
O her yerinde uzaklaşmanız uzaklaştırır
Gül bu değildi bu bölgeyi daha çok
kaybediyoruz arkadaşsınız
ve Bazen o Siz konular için karmaşık
çözümler ararız bırakalım öyle
sürdürülebilirlikle ekolojik bir falan
gibi havalı tahmini arkasına gizlenmeyi
Sen bugün Evet tam şu an bu Denizi bu
bölgeye o başına ne geleceğini karar
verebilirsin atılmak
bu insanlar zaman geçirdikleri alanlara
sahip çıkarlar odanı toparla Yatağın
üzerine bahçe Neyi gelirsin Eğer ki
değil seni gündelik hayatında
kullanmadığım bir arada dönüşürse bu
Deniz Kimin Umrunda olsun ki
bu
Karadeniz'in ölüm noktası olabilir
burada işer sözcüğü nesiller denize ve
doğasına sahip çıkarak bu bölgenin
kaderini değiştirebilir
Hatta değiştirmeye başladı bile
ve bugüne itibaren E sizin yarattığınız
dağlara ve sizi yaratan dalgaları
odaklanmayı davet ediyorum hadi binlerce
şey geliyor Teşekkürler
[Alkış]
Erol o